hey everybody its charlie this is gonna
be my non-spoilery spider-man into the
spider verse review will cover the
mythology the world-building because
they did confirmed that a sequel is
being made right now and there's another
spider-gwen spin-off that they just
confirmed so once we talk about the
actual film I'll talk a little bit about
where they're taking this animated
universe but if you saw the trailers for
this movie and you wondered if they
would try to do an animated universe of
films it is now confirmed so if you're
brand new to the channel there's a new
round of that spider-man ps4 game
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
the video there's so many things that we
have to talk about with this film the
visual style what it does with the
characters how it invokes all previous
spider-man films because if you're a big
fan of the classic spider-man films and
you really love hunting Easter eggs and
Marvel films in general this movie will
keep you busy for a long time it is
probably one of the most rewatchable
spider-man films that I've seen you may
see a lot of critics online calling it
their favorite superhero film of the
year I wouldn't go so far as to say that
the year isn't over yet and infinity war
is gonna be really hard to top but if
you're not a big animation geek the
really cool thing that they did is is
obviously it's all computer animation
like Pixar films or the Disney Animation
films but they did it in a way that made
it feel more like a 2d living comic book
there are a couple of other productions
that have tried to do that this year
unsuccessfully but spider-verse I feel
like perfected that technique and it's a
film so they spent a lot longer trying
to perfect that they spent a lot more
money on it that really comes across on
screen it's a visually very beautiful
film and because it's animation it's
much more precise than a live-action
film it's a lot easier for them to do
exactly what they're envisioning in
their minds and that also spills over
into the story mythology aspect of the
film because at a certain point
live-action films just become too
expensive like there was a version of
Thor fighting the Midgard serpent and
infinity war that they just had to cut
out because it was way too expensive so
because of the sheer multiverse
spider-verse
aspect of it all is probably the biggest
spider-man film that's ever been made in
terms of scope Andrew Garfield
spider-man tried to get there with
sinister six never quite achieved that
full big world that
they were going for but thanks to the
lack of limitations and animation you
hit the ground running with big
multiverse storyline in this without
completely drowning out the miles arc of
it all because it's meant to be his film
and if you've ever read the Bendis
ultimate spider-man storylines they're
doing a version of that mixed with the
spider-verse storyline from a couple
years ago so it doesn't feel like it was
that long ago but the character Miles
Morales only debuted in the comics about
seven years ago so compared to Peter
Parker he just doesn't have nearly as
much comic-book history to draw from but
the cool thing about including the
40-something midlife crisis Jake Johnson
Peter Parker is that they still find a
really cool way of giving you those
classic spider-man deep cuts so I think
the brilliant thing about them including
this particular version of spider-man is
that he gets to be sort of the
sweatpants pizza loving obi-wan Kenobi
of the film so you get to find out what
went wrong for him and you get a Peter
Parker art where he gets his [ __ ]
together late in life while also helping
miles get his [ __ ] together as a brand
new spider-man if you've ever seen any
other thing that Jake Johnson has done
he's known for playing characters like
that it just really iconic that he gets
to play a version of Peter Parker the
Miles Morales performance was great I
loved what they did with that character
you saw spider-man homecoming so you've
seen a very recent example of a high
school age Peter Parker that just trying
to balance all the different worlds he
belongs to how do you be a really great
superhero without destroying your
personal relationships with your friends
and family and avoid getting kicked out
of school because you're still a little
kid that has to graduate like everyone
else like you have a bright future as a
human being but also as a superhero and
how do you reconcile those two things so
the miles of this film is even younger
than Peter Parker was in spider-man
homecoming so the movie does a good job
of differentiating him from Peter Parker
because there are certain aspects of
their life that seem very similar but
miles his origin story in his background
the place where he lives his family is
all very different from Peter Parker's
situation so the writers did a really
good job with that balancing act of
giving you all this heavy mythology in
the really cool comic book stuff like
the plot and story of it all without
losing sight of the character work and
miles just trying to find his way and
learn to forge his own path because as a
young kid as you would expect he has a
lot of people that he looks up to and
seeks advice from some of them good some
not so good on one hand you have
sweatpants Peter Parker trying to tell
him learn from my mistakes don't do it
exactly like I did be your own
spider-man all you have to do save one
person then on his other shoulder he has
his uncle the Prowler trying to push him
in a different direction
thankfully the film is not a mess
because when you do really big
multiverse stories like this sometimes
it can cause a lot of havoc with the
character work but if you remember the
story about Dan Harmon being brought in
late in the game during the Doctor
Strange movie to punch up the script
recently the other writers revealed that
the reason that he was brought in was
because of community and his work on
Rick and Morty not so much for jokes but
because on those TV shows Kevin Feige
and Marvel felt like he does an amazing
job of conveying really complex ideas
like travelling between alternate
realities or the Citadel of Rick's which
itself is based on the Fantastic Four
Council of reads conveying all those
really crazy complex ideas in fast
really simple entertaining ways for
general audiences so when the
spider-verse the writers do a really
great job of conveying all these really
complex multiverse ideas in really
simple ways and it just works really
well for any audience so if you're a big
Easter Egg hunter longtime spider-man
fan and you'll love the mythology of it
all but if you're someone that has
children or you're taking your parents
to the film it'll work for them too when
the movie actually does hit theaters
I'll do a big Easter egg video but a lot
of the stuff in the film that they do
especially with the Peter Parker
character harkens back to Tobey Maguire
era Andrew Garfield and some Tom Holland
MCU spider-man stuff the way they
described their version of Peter Parker
the Jake Johnson Peter Parker is that
he's meant to be the older iteration of
an amalgam of those characters so you
have to imagine that this is like the
late 40-something Iron Man in the MCU
right now like what would happen to
Peter Parker in his late 40s if he were
to lose his way they implied that they
were trying to canonize certain aspects
of those eras from the spider-man films
in those storylines so we could talk
more about that when we get to Easter
egg videos Hailee Steinfeld was great as
spider-gwen John Mulaney was great as
spider-ham
which was just totally cartoony in the
way that they drew his character was
also meant to be more cartoony than the
other spider-verse characters this is a
way to honor the ridiculousness
of that character because it is crazy
that he's on screen with these other
characters even though it is animation
penny Parker was great and I cannot say
enough about Nicolas Cage he was born to
be in comic book movies but for whatever
reason things just didn't work out and a
lot of earlier roles back in the early
2000s he's finally getting to do really
awesome comic book characters albeit
through animation in Spider Man noir is
just a really cool character to begin
with but as you would expect it's a
Marvel based character film there is a
post-credits scene do not leave the
theater early we can talk about what
that is when the film actually comes out
but if you didn't see the news they
already started making a spider-verse
sequel it'll be led by Marvel's a
version of Peter Parker will probably
return spider-gwen will probably be back
but beyond that we'll just have to wait
for the film to come out because the end
of the film sets up those future sequels
like you would expect so if you've read
spider get in if you read any of the
spider verse comic book storylines any
of that stuff and those characters are
fair game for future spider-verse
sequels they've also confirmed that
there is a spider-gwen spin-off film
they'll have a whole bunch of other
female versions of spider-man
so Jessica drew spider woman silk madam
web may Parker spider girl penny Parker
might return for that as well
but it's meant to be separate from the
spider verse sequel so like I said a
spider verse of animated films like
their own animated version of an MCU
with spider-man based characters so
we'll get more details about that really
soon but what'll happen is is I know
everybody's wondering about Avengers 4
trailer and all the big Marvel MCU stuff
that's going on so I'll have more videos
for that posting soon leave your
requests in the comments below and I'll
name a giveaway winner when I pose that
new Marvel video but click here to
rewatch that once upon a Deadpool
trailer that's coming up in December and
click here to learn about what's going
on with the venom sequel thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you